Một chiến em một giới trước phía liin xò biệt, hôm một phía hai chữ ở trên khắp cả nước để được sơ tảm,
khi xe bà ố phượng hoàn tính gần đạo lúc sông.
Cần bà ở đây gây ra hai chừng hợp tiến mặt, gồm một người phụ nước sống mình từ tuổi,
bị vui là bởi tình sả mà và một người chết đối, tại Khathanh Dunas.
Cơ quan khi tuổi cũng cũng cạnh bà, là cần bà phượng hoàn đồ bộ và tình ở Rồi ra vào giận xã này,
một mời tấm mình một măng theo một lượng mưa hơn hai chăm mì lấy, và gió mạnh cấp xe bà.
Cạnh bà, các năm mức cầm nhất đã được bán bố tại mình đông ngang lúc giống.
Chúng khi cú vực tuổi đông màn lạ đặc trung phương cạnh bà,
chính phụ Philippines đã yêu cầu đón gửa toàn bộ trưng học, cơ quan hành trính,
vào huy hơn má trưng trưng bây, khiến các tình bánh biệt đã thần trưng giá cô đi điều,
sơ tả người dân khỏi vũi hềm, để giảm thiệu thứ trải khi cân báo đồ bộ.